yes one of the most inevitable
announcements in sport it has taken
quite a few days but after an awful lot
of pressure mark arthur the chief
executive of yorkshire county cricket
club has
this evening in the last uh half an hour
stepped down from his role here at
headingley he is the man who has
overseen the running of the club during
the time when it has been dealing with
the racism allegations made by former
player azeem rafiq
and in a fairly extraordinary statement
tonight
mark arthur the former now chief
executive of this club
has uh announced that decision he said
i've had eight fantastic years at the
yorkshire county cricket club working
alongside an outstanding group of people
and together achieving many highlights
and then he goes on to talk about the
many good things that he has done for
this club including rebuilding one of
the stands introducing the professional
women's cricket to headingley
also the six-year south asian engagement
program but among that long list of his
achievements at this club is no mention
of
the racism allegations that have plunged
this club into a complete crisis a
commercial and reputational
moment like i don't think any sporting
institution has seen uh certainly in
recent times and it has been under his
tenure but there is no mention of that
in his resignation statement no mention
of azeem rafiq the player who has been
at the center of all this who has been
acknowledged as a whistleblower who the
new chairman who has come in lord patel
has said should be believed and they've
uncovered a very disturbing pattern and
culture of racism that has existed and
been investigated under the tenure of
mark arthur he has finally gone tonight
on a day which joe root the prominent
yorkshire batsman who of course is also
the england test captain has spoken for
the first time at length about the
racism scandal here at
his home club a club he's represented
for the last 14 years
and he spoke earlier to us um
about the way in which from his point of
view cricket needs to change he needs to
confront this head-on and we asked him
directly whether or not he himself had
been
uh aware of any racism during his time
playing for yorkshire county cricket
club in a very uh
high-profile role and he said no he
wasn't aware of that but he's clearly
acknowledging that there has been a
problem here at headingley
so i think the most important thing that
we have to look at right now is is how
how we move forward as a sport how we
move forward as a society as well i
think this is deeper than just cricket i
think what we need to do
um is
is address what's what's happened um and
find ways of educating more find ways of
moving forward
and and really looking at um
you know areas in which we as a
as a sport and beyond that as well um
can
can really look to to better that you
know better society and better the game
the point of joe root saying that he
couldn't recall or remember any
direct or overt examples of racism
during his time as part of one of the
key figures of this club uh has led to a
quite pointed response from azeem rafiq
his former teammate who of course has
made his allegations in his view he has
said that this club is institutionally
racist and that is something that they
are trying to grapple with and
understand
azim rafiq tweeted today to say
disappointed is not even the feeling
incredibly hurt but uncomfortable truths
are hard to accept it seems that a
direct response to what joe root had
said about not being aware of racism at
this club
this will continue to run it's been
another busy day of developments within
this scandal but next tuesday azeem
rafiq himself and we think mark arthur
then our former chief executive roger
hutton the former chairman those two
very high profile senior managers at
this cricket club will be giving
evidence before mps at the
dcms select committee in parliament as
they try to unpick this and they will be
uh i think
it is pretty clear that there will be
further accusations made by azeem rafiq
and this could yet still uh have more
developments and more recriminations
after what has been one of the most
bruising episodes in sport played out
here at headingley